(Music)
(Applause)
Thank you.
Imagining a solo cello concert,
one would most likely think of Johann Sebastian Bach
unaccompanied cello suites.
As a child
studying these eternal masterpieces,
Bach's music would intermingle
with the singing voices of Muslim prayers
from the neighboring Arab village
of the northern Kibbutz in Israel
where I grew up.
Late at night, after hours of practicing,
I would listen to Janis Joplin and Billie Holiday
as the sounds of tango music
would be creeping from my parents' stereo.
It all became music to me.
I didn't hear the boundaries.
I still start every day
practicing playing Bach.
His music never ceases
to sound fresh and surprising to me.
But as I was moving away
from the traditional classical repertoire
and trying to find new ways
of musical expression,
I realized that with today's technological resources,
there's no reason to limit
what can be produced at one time
from a single string instrument.
The power and coherency
that comes from one person hearing, perceiving and playing all the voices
makes a very different experience.
The excitement of a great orchestra performance
comes from the attempt to have a collective of musicians
producing one unified whole concept.
The excitement from using multi-tracking,
the way I did in the piece you will hear next,
comes from the attempt
to build and create a whole universe
with many diverse layers,
all generated from a single source.
My cello and my voice are layered
to create this large sonic canvas.
When composers write music for me,
I ask them to forget what they know about the cello.
I hope to arrive at new territories
to discover sounds I have never heard before.
I want to create endless possibilities
with this cello.
I become the medium through which the music is being channeled,
and in the process, when all is right,
the music is transformed
and so am I.
(Music)
(Applause)